mes chers compatriotes
aujourd'hui tout commence je veux faire
se lever un espoir
lundi je reprendrai mon tour de france
pour aller vous rencontrer et vous
convaincre et ça commencera
effectivement dans la vallée de la
vésubie sans faux fuyant je dirai la
vérité sur les défis qui nous attendent
et sans relâche je proposerai des
solutions audacieuses pour nous
redresser
je ne serai pas une présidente du zig
zag et de la godille politique qui dit à
chacun ce qu'il a envie d'entendre entre
le président sortant et moi il y a plus
qu'une différence de ligne politique
il y a une différence de nature
emmanuel macron n'a qu'une seule
obsession c'est plaire moi je n'ai
qu'une seule passion sait faire
[Applaudissements]